rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message change
yourself
over to you Jack Ma when I said the
business cuz it's so difficult to be a
small business owner in China it took me
five months to one slide on your
daughter's that's stupid no chance and
it is it is and I have no any idea about
how to run a business and when I go to
register company called Internet the
register officer said no there's no such
a word in tanning and dictionary [ __ ]
register and Internet so he said we have
to register another name say he was it
what's the names a consulting firm and I
have no idea that what is computed so my
first company's pounds of hope his
computer consigning friend it was tough
it was not knowing anything about no
technology without knowing anything
about a computer past of 15 years
emerging I call myself like a blind man
riding on the back of the bright Tigers
those experts riding horses they all
fell we survived it was rewarded by the
future with relief the future we change
ourselves we never complete your
business needs to be a constant
reflection of who you are as a person or
wolfing this happens to so many
entrepreneurs you start a business
around an idea around the dream around a
passion and it takes a while to get
going but you build it up but you start
getting some customers you sir give me
some momentum and then what often
happens so often happens is you've end
up buying yourself a job that the thing
that was exciting and interesting to you
and groundbreaking
then becomes boring then you're just
filling orders and you're just doing the
same thing over and over and over and
over again and that's when you hear
entrepreneurs say I'm bored on my
business I need to do something else I
feel like I got myself a job
this sucks and what happens was at the
beginning everything was great because
you were evolving you were growing you
were the translate that some kind of
commercial
success but as you brew as a human being
as your interest changed as you grew as
you wanted to learn new things and
explore new paths and avenues you were
growing but your business was staying
flat your business kept doing the same
thing over and over and over and over
again where you started to rise and now
the bigger that gap gets right the
bigger that gap gets say that three
times fast and david gap gets there your
gap gets bigger gap gets the more
unhappy you're gonna be if you're way up
here from from a personal emotional
growth level and your business is down
here doing the same old boring thing
you're gonna be really unhappy and so
the key is your business needs to evolve
alongside you your business needs to be
a constant reflection of who you are as
even being as you grow as you change is
you evolved if you get a new interest
something new you want to test out you
have to bring that to your business
constantly and most people get to that
such a big gap that they're forced to
either sell their business or make a
massive change what you want to do is
continually evolve it so that that gap
gets a little big
you know just starts to grow and then
you close it and then starts to grow and
then you close it starts to grow and you
close it anytime you feel a little bit
of discomfort satisfaction unhappiness
boredom don't let it grow and fester
they be this huge thing fix it
add something more in I don't just do
the same exact videos all the time if I
did I would be bored even for series
that have continued for a long time if
you look at the top end series that
we've had around for a while it's still
not the same like watch what yesterday's
top 10 video and look at the first one
just a lot of changes you may not notice
it changes from from month to month
because we make minor tweaks adjustments
along the way but it's a big change from
where we started because that's
invigorating that's exciting I need to
add that in for me to feel happy if I
ever get to the point where YouTube
making these videos is a chore that's it
I'm out I quit like sell it or just drop
it and watch something else because if
you are doing work that you don't love
will never be successful if you're doing
work because it's a job and just
maintaining you're never gonna build
something great like the work you do has
to matter you have to show up and feel
like your time matters like the projects
that you're working on will make a
difference somehow that are inspiring
and passionate when you lose the passion
that's when you quit and you got to sell
up to something else
don't just lose the passion as it starts
to fade recognize it and make
adjustments along the way this
philosophy also applies to relationships
it's not just business I was having a
conversation with someone on my team
that was dating a guy and was asking
well how do I know if it's gonna work
out how do I know if we're meant for
each other and it's gonna you know like
things are great now but how do I know
if it's gonna still be great in 30 years
or 40 years and the answer is can you
grow together your interests and
passions desires that you have right now
will change over time look maybe right
now you love going skating together and
you love watching movies together or you
love drawing together or whatever it is
that may change like you may go off and
want to go to Tony Robbins events or go
ice pathing with wim HOF or whatever the
thing is that you want to go off and do
and learn from an experience and if they
don't do it with you it's not interested
in it
then you've gone off had this amazing
experience right and you've changed as a
human being right you start up here you
go up here you've changed right not as a
gap between you and if you keep going
off and changing and they're not coming
along the rides is that gap and if
they're off change in doing their own
thing going up to their own events and
seminars then this gap just keeps
getting bigger and bigger to the point
where like you don't recognize each
other then you're in a relationship ten
years later with this person that you
just bought yourself a job it's the same
thing as an entrepreneur you bought
yourself a job you're just following
through the motions and you get all of
your excitement your invigoration your
growth from outside your relationship
with your significant other you're off
doing your own thing and it's not that
you have to be a photocopy so I don't
you can do everything all the time
together right like the differences is
exciting but there has to be enough that
you guys can grow together don't assume
that all your interests and passions
that you have right now will still be
the same interest and passion that you
have in 30 40 years that they won't be
grow you evolve your change and your
partner has to go on that journey with
you so you're more looking at okay can
this person grow with is this person
interested in some of the new things
that I'm bringing in so if I look at me
and Nina as an example you know I'm a
difficult person to be in a relationship
with I think I think it's easier to be
in a relationship with Nina than it is
with me mostly because I'm always I'm
iLike variety I like injecting new
things I'm not satisfied
just the status quo and so I also get
really impatient when I come up with a
new idea I want to try something like
it's happening right now so right now
I'm packing my sleep and so I do lights
out at 10:00
10 o'clock lights off device is off TV
off computer off phone off everything is
off one little tiny kitchen light just
so they can kind of see where you're
going
I got a demystify earthing that that
shoots up lavender smell lavender oil in
the room to help us sleep right just
bought a sound machine gonna test that
out right I'm trying to hack my sleep
Nina always comes along for the ride
Nina doesn't always come up with the
ideas of what to do but she's always
supportive the ideas that I have because
that's hard to do without the support of
your wife if I said lights have it off
at 10:00 no TV no devices no computers
no phones that's hard to do without the
support right if she wanted lights on
and watching TV all night I'd have to
like go to the bedroom by myself and do
lights out and do my own thing and she's
separate from it and then maybe I
experience this amazing sleep and
everything is awesome and she's enjoy me
on that journey I'll keep going off on
this on this deep journey and and we're
growing more and more apartment and so
one of the things that I love about Nina
is that she always wants to join me in
what I'm doing she's always willing to
give things a try she came with me to
the Tony Robbins event she came with me
to whim hop they go sit in the ice bath
she joins me on my crazy adventures and
deals with the spontaneity that when I
come up with something I'm gonna do it
and we're gonna make it happen right now
zero patience like we're not waiting
five years of this we're just gonna go
and that works and I love it and and
that's why Nina and I know it's not
perfect you know everybody has issues
but being able to grow together I think
is really really really important you
know the people in your life you look at
like high school friends that maybe you
don't get along with anymore because you
both just going on different paths like
you don't relate to them anymore they
think different things and you think you
wouldn't be friends today if you didn't
have that connection back to the past
because you ruin the group this happens
if your business doesn't grow if your
relations and grow as you grow as a
human being then
beyond then your business will failed
interrelationships will fail growth and
progress is happiness and so just pay
attention to that it starts with you as
you change yourself you've got to be
with people who want to change with you
you've got to alter your business along
with you so there's always a source of
inspiration of encouragement of
uplifting of you being able to challenge
yourself and that you don't just buy
yourself a job and so my question today
today is what is the thing that you do
in your business to keep it exciting so
that you don't have a job and that you
are not excited every single moment of
every day but net-net
your passion about doing the work that
you do how do you keep things
spontaneous I'd love to hear from you
leave it in the comments below I also
want to give a quick shout out to Jane
come GC will probate Jane thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and posting it on LinkedIn
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you and I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events best
[Music]
how people live their lives as a result
of the story they believe about
themselves and when you have your
program and your guess and as is your
ideas of how they move through the
things that affect them what you do is
interrupt their story I tell speakers I
train sneakers how to discover their
story how to tell their story and how to
transform people individually and
collectively by creating an experience
when I came into the speaking industry
was based upon the the book Thinking
Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill and Napoleon
Hills book was a good book if they
consider that the Bible of the
motivational speaking industry well I
come to know because of my mentor Mike
Williams in Columbus Ohio he wrote the
book called the road to your best stuff
he said less if information could change
people everybody would be skinny rich
and happy right so he said in order to
change people you have to create a
significant emotional event that you
have to interrupt a person's story that
they believe about themselves with your
story and through the delivery of your
stories strategically you dismantle
their current belief system and inspire
them to make new choices because at the
end of a presentation if you don't
change how persons see themselves and if
you don't expand their vision of
themselves beyond their mental
conditioning and their circumstances and
begin to allow them to get a larger
vision of themselves and begin to ignite
their spirit you touch their hearts and
as a result they leave your presence
feeling better about themselves but
making new choices because when you
change how they see themselves all you
have to do after that is to get out of
the way I was very fortunate to
be taught with some of the best chefs
anywhere in the world and the most
important lesson I learned with passing
that knowledge on and always asked that
amazing question if you're such a
hands-on share fresh from turf who does
the cooking we're not there but it's the
same people when I am there there's no
difference so I have an unselfish way of
teaching people to invest in their
palate to get it as strong as mine I
tried to save him as lazy to coffee
anybody can copy so take 25% of
everything you've learned from other
chefs and then put yourself on the plate
and over the years of experience reduce
me less and improve yourself for that's
that's the foundation to becoming a
great chef
education is key why not instead of
watching another series that everybody's
talking about
use that exact time and go online and
watch a couple of these tutorials
because that's what inspires me I
learned a lot of tricks for producing
making specific sounds you know how can
I make this pad and make it sound really
wide how gonna make this transfer really
how do you program that I'll kind of
make my kick sound really fat how can I
have that clap with the big reverb
behind it and reverse it and how do you
do that how can how do I arrange my song
do I have enough elements to arrange my
so all these questions and a million
more you get you find answers online I
promise you as soon as you've finished a
couple of these courses you'll be so
inspired and the music will start
writing itself raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion and now
one drop of most self-worth depends on
your it's supposed to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be
that are completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten rows a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details